- So we have something
interesting going on.
I have this ring of conductor
right here, this square ring,
it has a resistance of two
ohms, we see that it is
two meters by two meters so the area
of this ring would be four square meters
and we see a magnetic field going through
the surface defined by the
ring and it's constant,
it's a constant magnetic
field of five teslas
and it's going exactly perpendicularly to,
perpendicularly to the
surface of the ring.
Now what we're going to happen, what we're
going to see happen is
over the next four seconds,
and this is going to
happen at a linear rate,
it's going to happen at a constant rate,
we're going to see the magnetic
field over four seconds
go from five teslas to 10
teslas so it's going to
double over those four
seconds and by doing so
we're going to have a change in flux.
Let's think about what the change
in flux is over this four seconds.
So our initial flux, let
me write it over here,
so flux, let me use a different color
and at any time if you are so inspired
I encourage you to pause the video
and figure out what our change in flux is.
So our flux, flux initial
is going to be, well it's the
it's going to be the
constant magnetic field,
you could say the average magnetic field
over the surface but since it's constant
that's just going to be
five teslas, so five teslas
and it helps for, it
helps us in this problem
that the magnetic field
vectors are exactly
perpendicular to the
surface, to the surface
defined by the ring, if
they weren't we would
have to find the component
that is perpendicular
but we have that right
over there so we have
the five teslas, that's
the average magnetic field
or the average component
of the magnetic field
that is perpendicular to the surface,
so five teslas times
the area of the surface.
So times, well two meters
times two meters is four
square meters so that
is going to be equal to,
that is equal to 20
tesla meter squared,
tesla meter squared, fair enough.
Now what's the final,
what's the final flux?
The final flux, flux final
is going to be equal to,
well now the average magnetic field or
the average components
of the magnetic field
that are perpendicular in the way
I've defined this magnetic field,
the vectors are already perpendicular
is 10 teslas, so 10 teslas.
The area of our ring hasn't changed,
it's still four square meters,
so times four square meters,
and so what is this going to be?
So our final flux is going to be
final flux is going to be 40,
40 tesla meters squared.
So what is our, what
is our change in flux?
Let me write this over here,
our change in flux, change in
flux, which is going to be our final flux
minus our initial flux is going to be
40 tesla meters squared minus
20 tesla meters squared,
which is just going to be
20 tesla meters squared.
So we figured out the change
in flux, we actually know
the change in time is
going to be four seconds
and actually using that
we can now figure out
what the voltage induced is going to be,
the voltage induced, or
the voltage that's going
to now induce, induce a current.
And if you were to look up
Faraday's law on the internet,
you were to look up for a
formula for Faraday's law
you would see something
that looks like this,
you would see voltage
generated is equal to
negative and, at least
if you're not using the
calculus version of it, negative
N times our change in flux,
change in, let me write
change in flux not just flux,
change in flux, delta flux
over change in time.
So one way to think about
this, and to do this problem
right we're assuming we have a constant
or the rate of change
is constant in our flux
so you have your average
rate of change of your flux
and then you're going
to multiply it times N.
N is actually the number of
loops you have, or you can
think of it as the number
of surfaces defined by it.
In this exact example,
in this exact example
N is just going to be
one, we just have one loop
so that simplifies it right over there
and then, so this is going
to be, and you might say
what is this negative
because it's a bit of
a strange thing because
you know, how are we
defining direction, you
know what's in the--
and all of that and that's
why I'm a little bit,
I'm not a huge fan of this negative sign.
This is, you know if you
look it up in a textbook
they'll often say, and
you're not using calculus,
they'll say, oh this
reminder to use Lenz's law,
they'll write literally Lenz's law
and I would say if they
want a reminder to use
Lenz's law why don't they just remind you
to use Lenz's law instead of putting
a kind of bizarre negative sign there.
And the negative sign
actually does make sense
if you were, if you were doing kind of the
using the vectors here and taking the,
and using a little bit of the,
well, doing more sophisticated mathematics
but this is just saying
that the voltage induced
is going to be in a direction so to
induce a current whose, whose induced
magnetic field will go in the direction,
will counteract the change in flux,
so that's just Lenz's law there.
So the real key here, at
least for this example
is to find our change in
flux over change in time
or our average, our average
rate of change in flux
and what is this going to be?
Well this is going to be
20 tesla meters squared,
that was our change in flux
right over there divided
by our change in time,
which is four seconds, over four seconds,
which is going to be equal to, and I'll,
I could throw that negative
there if we want to,
that negative 20 divided by four is five,
five tesla meters squared or square meters
per second and this actually
turns out to be a volt,
so we could say this
is negative five volts,
negative, negative five volts,
negative five volts.
So if you have a voltage of,
well let's just say five volts,
we can think about the negative later,
if you have a voltage
of five volts across a,
across a circuit that has
a resistance of two ohms
what is the current, what
is the current going to be?
Well we just have to remind ourselves
V is equal to I-R
or voltage is equal to
the current divided by
the resistance, or voltage is equal to
the current times the
resistance or you could say
that the current, the current is equal to
the voltage divided by the resistance.
So in this case the
current, the current induced
is going to be the voltage
and I'm just going to
focus on its absolute value now, we can
think about its direction in a second.
It's going to be its voltage, five volts
divided by the resistance, so two ohms,
two ohms, which is going to be equal to,
this is going to be equal to 2.5, 2.5
amperes, 2.5 amperes.
So we now know the
magnitude of the current
that's going to be induced while we
have this change in flux, remember this
is going to happen while, over the course
of those four seconds, as
we have this rate of change
of flux, this average
rate of change of flux,
which we'll assume is the
actual rate of change of flux,
we're assuming that it's
changing at a constant rate
and so while it is changing we
were just able to figure out
that it would induce a
current of 2.5 amperes.
Now the next question
we should ask ourselves
and this is where this
little negative comes in,
is a reminder for us to
use Lenz's law is, well
which direction is that
current going to go in?
Is it going to go in, let
me pick two orientations,
is it going to go in a,
in a clockwise direction,
is it going to go that way
over the course of this change in flux
or is it going to go in a
counterclockwise direction,
is it going to go that way?
And to think about that
we just have to use
the right hand rule, take our right hand,
point our thumb in the direction
of the proposed direction of the current
and so if we went with
this one, our right hand,
our right hand would look like this,
I'm literally taking
my left hand out and--
I mean my right hand
out and I'm drawing it
and I'm looking at it to
think about what would happen,
so that's my right hand
so if I use the right hand
if the current went in this
direction then it would
induce a magnetic field that went,
that went like this and
so if the current went
in this direction the
magnetic field it induces
inside the surface would only
reinforce the change in flux
so it would only add to
the flux so, and it's going
in the same direction
as the change in flux,
which would just keep us, you know as we
talked about in the Lenz's law video,
that would turn into just
this source of energy
that comes out of nowhere and defies
the law of conservation of energy so this
absolutely not, is not
going to be the direction
and so we know that the direction
is going to be in a clockwise one.
So the current, the 2.5 ampere current
is going to flow, is
going to flow like that,
and we're done!
By thinking about our change in flux
and how long it's taking us,
we were able to figure out
not only the magnitude of
the current, we were able
to figure out the
orientation of the direction
that it's actually going to flow in.